Übung 5 einbeiniges Gleichgewicht
starten Sie in einem schulterbreiten
stand an einer Wand so dass ein Bein
diese berührt der Arm dieser Seite lehnt
ebenfalls mit der Außenseite dagegen
beugen Sie nun das Bein 90° im Knie und
Hüftgelenk an und halten den Kontakt
anschließend drücken Sie das Bein mit
Spannung gegen die Wand halten Sie auf
dem Standbein bei leicht gebeugtem Knie
die Balance und achten Sie auf Ihre
Beinachse halten Sie diese Position für
5 Sekunden und gehen Sie dann in die
Ausgangsstellung zurück wiederholen Sie
diese Übung 10 bis 15 mal mit einer
Pausenzeit von 5 Sekunden zwischen den
Wiederholungen